remember I said we went through this
process for this particular parabola
went through the from the from the
basics and we derived this equation for
the locus of this point okay and then I
said draw our derivative box around this
because this is an important form okay
now all of the parabolas of this form of
this or even if you swap the X's and Y's
around even if you slap a minus sign on
the front all of them still do one thing
in common namely every single one you
can see although one two three four that
I've drawn they all do the same thing
namely they pass through here their
vertices all of these vertices the
vertex for each one there are always at
the origin okay that's because as soon
as you put x equals zero here why cuz
you're at the other end okay so
therefore it doesn't take too much to
conclude well what if you don't want it
to be at the origin what would you want
what you do this thing we already know
right yeah bit okay so we introduced K
and H as these um very roots of choice
to indicate the X&Y coordinates of the
vertex now in this case H and K are both
not right as in X minus 0 squared is x
squared and y minus 0 is just Y ok so
that's why the vertex of this guy and
all his variations they're always at the
origin ok but if I want to move this
somewhere else I want to move it
somewhere else up down left right all I
have to do is vary these just like you
vary it for your original problems in
vertex form or a circle or anything like
that you still have that focal length
right there so for instance if you said
ok let's take
I'll put back this guy on the board X
square equals 32 why okay so you already
know that this is going to have a focal
length of what eight right just like all
these other ones do okay so let's think
about what might happen if I put this
somewhere else okay if I said mmm let's
have a go here let's go X minus three
squared equals thirty-two y plus one
okay let's think about this for a second
you can already still see if I take out
my factor of four I still have a focal
length of 8 are you okay with that focal
like this still eight now ordinarily for
this guy you would say the focus is
where focal length a it's going to be
zero eight because just that it's just
concave up right and you'd usually say
the directrix will be sorry y equals
negative eight it's got it's gone down
okay but now I've told you some things
about where the vertex is going to be
for instance I told you this whole thing
is just like this but moved how many
units and which way so he knows right
three units to the right okay so the
focus shouldn't be at zero and you nor
should it the focus should be at three
something right it's also been moved one
unit down so it shouldn't be at eight
anymore it should be at seven you see
that it's this guy but it's been shifted
this much okay and then one more thing
of course the directrix it doesn't
matter for this directions because it's
a horizontal line you can move it
horizontally
any way you like so I don't need to
worry about three but what does this
fail or is it down one just like this
will move down one so shouldn't be why
it was negative eight anymore it should
be negative nine okay it's been
down okay so the way I think about it is
come back to your legs simple one your
simple one that goes to the origin read
off the focal length and say here and
here that's where my focus is that's
what my directrix is and then you think
are shifting that guy right shift him
according to whatever coordinates you've
been provided and off you go you'll have
your new focus and you need directrix
okay